et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
philippe juvin bonjour bonjour connaîtra
un jour chef des urgences à l'hôpital
pompidou à paris vous êtes le maire de
la garenne colombes et vous êtes le
conseiller santé peuvent elles aider à
progresser on va bien sûr parler de ces
questions avec vous on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale pour aujourd'hui à faire ça ne
laisse pas bonjour aux reason bonjour
fils joseph la joie de sud ouest et on
commence évidemment par la crise
sanitaire avec vous philippe souvent
entendue mercredi soir olivier verront
dire que le pire était derrière nous est
ce que c'est ce que vous constatez est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec vous non
non c'est à dire que depuis le début de
l'épidémie depuis deux ans régulièrement
on entend le gouvernement dire ça y est
cocorico c'est fini promis dernière
vague bon en fait c'est une stratégie de
communication qui consiste de stratégie
positive qui en permanence nous explique
que ça va aller mieux donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya un moment où ça va marcher mais
aujourd'hui il n'ya là il n'y a pas
d'arguments scientifiques pour dire
c'est la dernière vague ce qui est
certain c'est qu'on voit depuis
plusieurs jours et le nombre de cas un
peu baissé le nombre d'hospitalisations
commencé à stagner mais il ya trente
mille personnes actuellement hospitalisé
en france donc déjà en compte peut pas
opérer d'autres pathologies on a passé
le pic de la vague lillois ne pensait
pas le pic vous savez on l'a passée à
billes et bien des jours après quand on
sait qu'on a passé il ya une personne
qui meurt du coc vide toutes les cinq
minutes aujourd'hui en france donc on
est encore nous sommes encore dans une
situation qui est une situation critique
il faut prendre ça avec beaucoup
beaucoup de prudence moi les communiqués
de victoire n'en sert les communiqués de
victoire vous savez voilà c'est en a
gagné je m'en méfie toujours il faut
être extrêmement prudent d'autant que si
vous me permettez il ya ce sujet du
coved donc on espère moi je suis comme
vous j'espère que ça va aller mieux mais
il ya aussi tout le sujet d'une sorte de
deuxième épidémie qui est aussi
importante et qui va poser un problème
de santé publique ce sont tous ces gens
des milliers de gens qui n'ont pas été
traités pour leur concert leurs maladies
du coeur les maladies mentales sur les
trois sujets principaux qui sont dans la
nature parce que les diagnostics n'ont
pas été posées et qui sont en train de
développer leur maladie
l'épidémie pourrait avec des vagues
aussi forte il ya des travaux qui laisse
entendre que par exemple sur les cancers
du côlon tube digestif le saint et la
prostate on pourrait avoir une
surmortalité de dix mille personnes dans
les dix années à venir donc on va avoir
une vague qui va s'étaler sur plusieurs
années de gens qui vont souffrir de
pathologies qui se sont développées à
cause de la désorganisation du système
pendant l'épidémie donc
des programmes et les opérations pour
faire de la place aux patients qui ont
dit non moi je crois que c'est tout le
sujet et là vous l'avez bien résumé
c'est que il ya les patients qu'aux vide
et puis il ya toutes les autres victimes
collatérales dont je ne parlais qui sont
la conséquence de la déprogrammation
majeur quand vous avez des dizaines de
milliers de lits qui sont fermées parce
que le système est désorganisée et bien
par définition vous créez de la
pathologie donc il faut arrêter de
déprogrammer il faut probablement que le
public et le privé travaillent mieux
ensemble ça va mieux aujourd'hui qu'il
ya deux ans mais c'est sûr pas un
cabanon il ya sûrement des marges
d'amélioration
et puis je pense que le sujet reste
toujours le même nous avons des lits
fermés aujourd'hui aussi parce que là
dessus se surajoute une vague de
fermeture due au fait qu'on a des
soignants qui qui ont décidé de faire
autre chose on considère qu' environ 20%
de lits fermés en france ce sont autant
de lait qu'on ne peut pas utiliser pour
opérer des cancers des maladies du coeur
et cédera juin il eut le séduire la
santé c'est un argument président de la
république vous qui est le conseiller
santé de valérie pécresse vous dites
quoi ce secteur de la santé qui a mieux
rémunérés qui a augmenté les salaires à
des soignants ou dit c'est suffisant
c'est va dans la bonne direction c'est
pas assez parce que valérie pécresse
elle a une proposition sur les salaires
notamment oui on met le ségur de la
santé a été placé il ya eu un effort du
pays qui est évident un effort à crédit
bien entendu d'une dizaine de milliards
donc il faut pas dire que c'est rien
sauf que c'est très insuffisant parce
que divisé par le nombre de soignants ça
fait une rémunération qui est en tête en
fait trop faible on est sur des
rémunérations dans les soignants en
france qui est qui restent encore
inférieurs aux moyennes de l' ocde nous
ce que nous voulons c'est quoi c'est
quoi notre proposition ça c'est bien de
commenter
un des sujets majeurs en matière de
santé c'est que nous ne formons pas
assez de gens pour soigner les français
ni les médecins ni les infirmières et
les aides-soignantes militantiste il
nous manque du monde partout donc il ya
il ya informé du monde il faut faire un
choc de formation et deuxièmement donc
par exemple sur les médecins nous allons
doubler le numerus clausus il va falloir
évidemment ce n'est pas simple on va
trouver des terrains de stage c'est pour
ça qu'il faut réfléchir à des stages y
compris en médecine de ville y compris
dans un établissement privé bref une
médiation
nouveaux médecins formés par an d'ici la
fin du quinquennat mais est ce que là on
n'est pas sur du long terme le temps que
le médecin se reforme après une dizaine
d'années vous avez raison est-ce que du
coup on n'est pas sur une table qu'est
ce qu'on fait pour le royal y ait
plusieurs choses à faire d'abord il faut
bien commencer depuis le temps qu'on
nous dit à mes former un médecin ça mais
dix ans ma part dont on aurait commencé
il ya dix ans dix ans je vous rappelle
que c'est emmanuel macron ces cinq ans
il était conseiller du président
hollande ministre cinq ans donc ça fait
dix ans on aurait commencé il ya dix ans
bah ça voilà déjà honoraires des
médecins qui sortiraient de la faculté
deuxièmement il faut un choc de
formation sur les professions
paramédicales les infirmières par
exemple qui seront formés en trois ans
donc ça va évidemment pour plus vite on
aurait commencé à former des infirmières
massivement au moment de l'épidémie il
ya deux ans elle serait quasiment formé
aujourd'hui on ne l'a pas fait et puis
troisièmement redonner du sens à des
sujets c'est qu'on a beaucoup de
personnel soignant qui décide d'arrêter
le soin vous savez qu'en france il ya 80
mille infirmières formées diplômés qui
ne travaillent plus pourquoi parce
qu'elles ne trouvent plus de sens à sont
fatiguées elles sont usées moi dans mon
service j'ai 21 postes d'équivalents
temps plein de médecin je n'ai que je
crois 16 2 postes pourvus donc je dépose
n'arrivait pas recruter non absolu et la
rémunération qui peut faire l'incitation
la rémunération et le sens que vous
donnez aux métiers l'autonomie quand
vous faites confiance au personnel en
fait ils se saisissent de cette
confiance ils l'exercent il exerce mieux
leur métier d'une certaine manière ce
que nous avons vécu lors de la première
vague au mois de mars à ce moment là
comme tout allait mal en fait les
soignants dans les hôpitaux affirmé un
médecin on a pris le pouvoir et on a
fait fi de toutes ces difficultés qu on
nous met des bâtons dans les roues en
permanence qui font que nous n'avons pas
de temps à consacrer aux patients ce que
nous voulons c'est que notre temps
médical ou paramédical soit consacrée
aux patients et pas à des tâches
administratives
quand vous donner du pouvoir aux sur le
terrain les gens se ressaisissent et
retrouvent du sens
c'est quand même pas ce qui s'est passé
à l'hôpital de valenciennes par exemple
laisser souffler ses vingt huit mois je
lis un besoin permanent charme ou est il
par valérie pécresse maintenant pourquoi
ça se contente uniquement à l'hôpital de
valenciennes c'est alors pour que les
gens comprennent l hôpital de saint
etienne qui est un hôpital public qui
travaille avec le statut de la fonction
publique avec le code des marchés
publics quoi ya pas de révolution ils
ont appliqué une méthode assez somme de
management ils ont dit aux soignants
médecins infirmiers prenez-vous en
charge gérez vous mêmes vos budgets
gérer vous même votre service et c'est
que ça il n'y a pas eu un un chef un
sous-chef un petit chef qui est venu
leur dire comment faire ben ils se sont
saisis des choses et encore une fois ils
ont eux-mêmes définit les conditions de
leur travail enfin quand il faut faire
confiance aux gens en fait d'une
certaine manière la grande leçon de la
crise je crois c'est évidemment la
question des masses des tests de
l'autonomie sanitaire d'un pays xterra
tout ça est important du progrès mais
c'est aussi la question de la confiance
quand vous avez une parole publique
descendante qui impose parfois moralité
moralisatrice quand vous avez un petit
chef un sous-chef une commission une
sous commission qui vous disent comment
faire vous n'y arrivez pas quand vous
dites aux gens vous êtes responsable du
truc eh bien les gens les gens
travaillent et sont efficaces et sont
heureux de travailler pourquoi ça se
fait qu'à valenciennes je pense que
c'est une où c'est une question d'ordre
quasiment sociologique ou voire
philosophique c'est à dire qu'en france
on a un pouvoir extrêmement centralisé
tout se décide à paris et je suis
frappée d'une chose j'ai demandé au
directeur de valenciennes mais pourquoi
vous arrivez à faire pourquoi les veaux
autres collègues directeurs d'hôpitaux
ne font pas mais me dis bah tenez vous
bien depuis dix ans le directeur de
valenciennes ils ont été 2 succéder n'a
jamais été invité une fois à prononcer
une conférence sur son type de
management très efficace à l'école de
santé draine qu'est l'école qui forme
les directeurs d'hôpitaux il faut casser
une hyper centralisation de la décision
qui fait que tout se décide à paris je
crois que une société moderne c'est une
société décentralisée y compris dans les
hôpitaux fils juin est ce qu'il faut
embaucher dans le système de la santé
parce que valérie pécresse veut
supprimer 150 mille postes de
fonctionnaires et en même temps on
recrée et d'autres dans les secteurs qui
éduque et qui soigne notamment
absolument assez lisible sa vouloir
supprimer d'un côté créé de l'autre en
fait l'arrivée la la la la réflexion que
valérie pécresse a et que nous avons à
plusieurs c'est qu'il n'y a pas de pays
prospère
si ce pays ne s'est pas éduquer les gens
les protéger et les soigner la
prospérité la condition première de la
prospérité c'est l'éducation c'est la
protection et c'est le soin il faut donc
des juges et des magistrats des
policiers il faut des professeurs et il
faut des soignants c'est pour ça qu'elle
a dit une chose très simple il faut
évidemment rendre la dépense publique
plus efficace on met beaucoup d'argent
dans le système de santé on en a pas
pour notre argent cet argent l'argent ne
va pas aux soins il va beaucoup
d'administrations ça on veut lutter
contre ça mais en même temps elle a
affirmé qu'elle embaucherait 25000
soignants donc on va sauver l'hôpital
public à la fois en réinjectant des
soignants est à la fois en dix ans dans
mes moins d'argent dans cette
administration administrante et
justement les cent cinquante mille
suppressions vous les trouvez ou
prenez pas dans la police si vous prenez
pas dans l'éducation si vous prenez pas
dans la santé vous prenez où je vous
donne un exemple c'est assez simple il
ya en france environ 480 mille personnes
qui travaillent dans des agences les
agences aux particuliers de contrôle
donc au contrôle le travail qu'un autre
fait et d'ailleurs on édite une norme
qui permet de nommer des contrôleurs de
la norme la france c'est devenu sa
patrick devedjian qui était président du
conseil départemental des hauts-de-seine
et qui est malheureusement décédé du coc
vide il ya deux ans avait fait un
travail il l'avait publiée montrant que
en ile de france un exemple parmi
d'autres quand vous voulez construire un
immeuble vous devez répondre à 22,2
niveau ou de normes ou d'organisme
administratifs qui vous contrôler on est
dans un monde devenu fou où tout le
monde contrôler tout le monde et donc du
coup ceux qui veulent travailler a hâte
de travailler et en plus ça coûte de
l'argent public donc les les
les gains de postes comme vous le dites
elles sont elle sera aussi le fruit est
la conséquence d'une plus grande
efficacité de l'action publique il ya
aussi la question des déserts médicaux
et d'accessoires valérie pécresse a dit
qu avaient un accès aux soins pour tous
français à moins de 30 minutes de son
domicile comme en france est fondamental
écouter aujourd'hui vous savez très bien
que quand vous avez quand vous déménagez
et que vous quittez votre médecin pour
vous en avez un eh bien vous avez
beaucoup de mal à retrouver sa scène
généraliste mais alors je vous parle
même pas du spécialiste essayer de
trouver un psychiatre essayer de trouver
un psychiatre pour enfants ok un désert
en fait on disait avant la 2e médical
s'était n'était le département ont
réussi c'est faux la france est un
désert médical il ya pas une zone en
france où vous pouvez vous dire il n'y a
pas de problème j'ai trouvé tout le
monde à l'hôpital je travaille à
l'hôpital pompidou qui est un hôpital
très moderne et très performant dans le
15ème arrondissement de paris c'est
l'hôpital le plus récent construit à
paris autour de nous il ya des médecins
généralistes s'installer la médiane
d'âge des médecins généralistes
installés ces 61 5 ans donc la moitié
des médecins ont plus de 61 ans quand
vous voyez que la situation est critique
aujourd'hui dans dix ans elle le sera
encore plus comment on fait un bon
double numerus clausus âge où les 10,2
c'est une proposition que j'avais faite
durant la primaire que pécresse a repris
à son compte qui consiste à dire d'une
manière très pratique pour pas attendre
dix ans on va prendre les internes en
médecine générale c'est à des étudiants
qui se dessine la médecine générale qui
aujourd'hui font trois ans d'internât là
où les autres spécialistes font quatre
ou cinq ans il donc ils vont va les
aligner sur les autres spécialistes ils
vont faire une quatrième année cette
quatrième année sera faite non pas à
l'hôpital évidemment mais elle sera
faite en ville et en particulier dans
les maisons de santé pluridisciplinaires
avec un encadrement avec des maîtres de
stage et pour que les gens comprennent
ce que ça signifie en pratique ça fait
une moyenne ce n'est qu'une moyenne de 2
médecins généralistes qui arriveront
pendant un an dans chaque maison de
santé de france donc là où vous avez une
maison de santé dans votre commune en
moyenne vous verrez vous verrez arriver
deux médecins supplémentaires et donc
c'est une manière très pratique de
lutter contre les déserts médicaux là
dessus je rajoute une dernière pris
notre armement notre armement évidemment
et multiples sur les déserts médicaux
c'est une priorité on va donner des
nouvelles tâches aux infirmières si vous
êtes soigné pour une hypertension
artérielle vous allez voir votre médecin
tous les six mois qui vous prend tension
qui vous examine vous pose des questions
et puis si tout va bien il vous
renouvelle votre ordonnance un certain
nombre de ces tâches pourraient être
faites par des infirmières spécialement
formés pour cela eh bien le gouvernement
depuis dix années qui va la faire j'ai
compté je crois qu'il ya quarante
infirmières en tout et pour tout pour
tout le territoire national qui ont été
formés à cette tâche très spécifique
d'infirmières de pratiques avancées qui
ne font que ça il y en a d'autres qui
feront 340 qu'est ce qu'on va rester sur
le domaine de la santé film juin avec ce
scandale dans les ehpad orpea et les
révélations sur livre les fossoyeurs
est-ce que vous avez constaté vous des
dysfonctionnements dans les ehpad en
tant que médecin votre médecin réalise
thesis la sueur animateurs non mais ça
de toute façon ce qui est dans le livre
moi je le dénonce le plus des années
depuis des années j'explique des choses
très simples quand vous avez une maladie
d'alzheimer vous avez du mal à déglutir
à chaque bouchée quand on vous donne à
manger il faut une heure pour faire
manger quelqu'un qui a des troubles de
la déglutition parce qu ils tous à
chaque bouchée comment voulez vous
qu'une aide soignante qu'à 25 personnes
à suivre donne à manger à 25 personnes
pendant une heure ce n'est pas possible
techniquement quand je m'intéresse à un
moment je me suis intéressé au nombre de
douches de douche dont les gens
bénéficiaires en ehpad j'ai voulu faire
une enquête je suis jamais arrivé à
faire enquête et j'ai eu des témoignages
absolument fou tous les gens qui me
disent eh ben moi j'ai une douche toutes
les cinq semaines ça a été ça a été la
clé de ces révélations donc moi je sais
que dans les ehpad ça ne va pas j'en
avais parlé d'huile d'ailleurs d'une
durant la primaire ce qu'on va faire
c'est la chose suivante premièrement
nous allons édicter des règles de vie
dans les ehpad c'est à dire qu'on va
dire dans les ehpad il faut des repas
qui durent tell tale et revient la norme
que vous dénonciez ce sont des critères
de qualité ces critères de qualité on va
les appliquer deuxièmement les ehpad qui
ne respecteraient pas ces normes de
qualité contrôlée dans des contrôles
inopinés ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de contrôles
inopinés on prévient toujours avant de
venir qu'est ce qui va se passer bien on
fermera ces ehpad troisièmement c'est
philosophique nous moi je veux changer
le nom d'ehpad établissement
d'hébergement
c'est pas un hébergement ça doit être un
domicile et ça change tout quand c'est
votre domicile et vous êtes chez vous on
peut pas vous empêcher de sortir ce
qu'on empêche aujourd'hui de faire on
peut pas vous empêcher de voir votre
chat devant lui quand vous êtes passés
de votre domicile à l'ehpad
la plupart du temps vous pouvez pas
prendre votre chat mais ça c'est pas
normal si les ehpad doivent redevenir
avant d'être des structures de soins des
domiciles aux et il ya des ehpad au vous
interdit de fumer dans votre chambre
c'est un domicile n'est pas les pattes
doit redevenir un domicile premier chant
et deuxième show et je suis très long
pardon je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait une
politique de maintien à domicile le plus
longtemps possible ceux qui veulent
rester dans leur domicile le leur eh
bien il faut qu'il puisse le faire
philippe juvin valérie pécresse tiendra
un grand meeting ce sera dimanche
prochain le 13 au zénith de paris est ce
que finalement ce meeting c'est quitte
ou double pour relancer une campagne qui
patine un peu non mais je j'aime bien
d'abord il ya toujours des gens qui nous
veulent du bien qui explique oui la
campagne va pas bien c'est difficile non
nouvelles du bien ils sont dans votre
qu'on va parler d'eux il ya eu il ya
trois étapes dans l'état première étape
une fois que valérie pécresse a été élu
je suis gap la cgt un des battus en
phase donc je le dis très très librement
le soir même de sa victoire elle a
appelé les quatre autres dont j'étais en
dix ans faisant l'union premièrement
elle tire les leçons de la débandade de
ya cinq ans en faisant l'union de la
droite et du centre puisque désormais
nous avons allait centrer s'est lui dit
avec vous donc elle crée une équipe ce
qui n'existait pas il ya cinq ans
première leçon deuxième partie elle met
des propositions qu'elle est ligne sur
des tas de sujets vous avez vu par
exemple la disparition des quasi
disparition des impôts sur les
successions et puis je vous ai parlé de
santé y compris on va le prendre des
idées de droite et de gauche chez tous
ses soutiens et bien derrière le xiii
c'est la troisième étape elle va faire
ce discours qui va coagulé un certain
nombre de propositions concrètes en
expliquant quel est son projet de france
une campagne électorale
ça s'inscrit dans la durée pour quoi que
ce 13 c'est le projet le groupe vision
de la france c'est très souvent le xiii
c'est la coagulation de propositions qui
ont été travaillés au plan technique
parce que c'est facile de faire des
propositions et si dernière vous ne
mettez pas en oeuvre en fait vous êtes
un mauvais candidat mais neil mac row
vous a fait mille propositions durant sa
campagne on n'a pas vu le début de
commencement par exemple sur le grand
âge soit disant qu'il allait faire voter
une loi grand âge on n'en a pas vu le
début de commencement nous nous faisons
des propositions qui sont techniquement
prête qui sont écrites il ya une cellule
chez nous qui écrit les projets de liste
tout ça fait que est le jour où nous
serons élus si les français nous font
confiance on aura 100 jours d'action et
au bout de 100 jours vous verrez la
france la nation sur ce meeting a bien
un côté quitte ou double parce que si
dans les sondages ça reprend pas là on
voit bien que valérie pécresse est
coincé entre eric zemmour et marine le
pen elle fait elle est au coude à coude
avec marine le pen pour le second tour
elle n'a toujours pas installé son duel
avec eva emmanuel macron dans cette
perspective là donc vous dites quoi il
ya encore du temps mais moins de 70
jours maintenant donc ça va vous savez
très bien qu'une campagne présidentielle
se coagulent dans les j'allais dire 3 à
4 semaines parfois même c'est les deux
trois dernières semaines on voit dans
toutes les élections précédentes le
bouleversement il a lieu dans le tout
dernier mois donc l'important c'est
d'être crédible nous ne faisons pas de
com nous avons des propositions
concrètes et surtout nous disons aux
français on vous fait des promesses mais
nous dans les 100 premiers jours et
trois premiers mois avant l'été nous
aurons réalisé une grande partie de nos
promesses chez moi il ya un truc qu'il
faut regarder valérie pécresse est
réélue présidente de région et de france
l'année dernière avant juin avant le
début septembre elle a réalisé 80% de
son programme elle a mis en oeuvre où
elle a créé les conditions pour son 80%
de son programme soit réalisé mais vous
parlez dans des décors vous parlez
beaucoup des propositions finales juin
et c'est justement un peu ce que vous ce
que vous reproche rachida dati à l'admin
interview dans le figaro et 10 la
campagne c'est pas qu'une somme de
propositions et 10 l'alignement de
propositions ne peut apparaître comme
une posture technocrates y ait qu est ce
que vous pensez ses propos de rachida
dati mais d'abord rachida dati qui fait
partie de notre majorité a absolument
raison de dire qu'une campagne ce n'est
pas qu'une à cannes alignement de
propositions les propositions en fait
elles ont un sens elle sous-tend d'un
sens et ce qu'on a l'impression que la
critique un peu en creux la campagne de
valérie pécresse ed c'est qu'il faut une
un second souffle non dans cette
campagne que il faut donner de
l'incarnation il faut il faut qu'elle
soit l'incarnation celle qui parle à
tous les français elle a du mal là
dessus nous à l'époque tout ça est vrai
dans une hutte dans une campagne il faut
donner de l'incarnation
objectivement c'est une c'est une
observation tout le monde partage moi ce
que je crois c'est que ce qui vous bien
combien manque d'incarnation non ce que
justement je pense que ce qui ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que toutes
ces mesures se sont pas des mesures
techniques
ce sont des mesures certes technique
parce qu'il faut les mettre en oeuvre et
qui ont un sens derrière quand on vous
dit on fait disparaître les impôts sur
les successions pour 95% des français
c'est une mesure technique mais en
réalité derrière ce signifie quoi c'est
que nous croyons que quelqu'un qui
travaille toute sa vie a le droit de
transmettre quelque chose à ceux qui
vont le suivre ça a un sens politique ce
n'est pas de la techno c'est un sens de
quelle est la société à laquelle je
crois nous croyons à une société de
transmissions co comprenons cela et puis
encore une fois la campagne il faut
jamais parler de petit ou double ça ne
veut rien dire une campagne c'est dans
la durée on a plusieurs semaines devant
nous je suis très critique sur la sur la
durée philippe juvin est ce que vous
attendez un soutien clair à naître de
nicolas sarkozy pour l'instant il est
silencieux
valérie pécresse a attendu quelques
perches avec la petite phrase sur le
kärcher voilà et l'ancien président et
s'ils ont su assez moi je suis un proche
de nicolas sarkozy vous savez ce qu'il
va la soutenir est ce qu'il va rentrer
dans cette campagne là évidemment mais
nicolas sarkozy celui qui a créé les
républicains et le chef c'est plus que
sa famille c'est lui qui est à l'origine
de la création de la bulle comment
peut-on croire à nos sens qui ne
soutiendra pas notre famille politique
j'étais avec lui et le soir où il a
perdu la primaire en 2016 avec lui
physiquement à la minute où il a perdu
la primaire il a pris le micro et il a
dit merci pour ceux qui ont voté pour
moi je soutiens le candidat dont je suis
le plus proche à l'époque françois
fillon il dit immédiatement il a soutenu
françois veillon donc évidemment il ne
fait pas évidemment mais pourquoi parce
que la campagne est longue saleh mois de
janvier c'est compliqué dans une
campagne présidentielle surtout qu'en
face on en a un qui fait campagne tout
en disant qu'il n'est pas candidat mais
avec votre carnet de chèques donc il ya
une sorte de troubles là dessus ensuite
vont arriver les vacances de février on
voit bien qu'on a plusieurs creux en
fait la campagne va commencer le jour où
les candidats qu'ils pensent être
candidats seront candidates du maquereau
exactement mais
vous verrez évidemment nicolas sarkozy
va soutenir son corps une chronique
n'est pas le sujet le dernier mot là
dessus parce que je reviens pardon à
rachida dati mais elle a dit moi je suis
pas dans la compagnie pas dans
l'organigramme de campagne donc je suis
libre de ma parole est ce que quand même
c'est pas symptomatique
du fait que peut-être que si les
sondages sont bons pour valérie pécresse
l'union quand vous mettez en avant elle
va se fissurer non non non ne dites pas
que les sondages ne sont pas bons enfin
si les sondages non mais semée par les
valérie pécresse est la seule qui est en
incapacité à battre emmanuel macron
c'est simple si vous voulez faire voter
si vous voulez qu emmanuel macron soit
votre président de république ce qui est
tout à fait légitime c'est la démocratie
vous avez au fait trois manières de
faire soit vous votez pour lui plus
logique soit vous votez pour monsieur
zemmour soit vous votez pas pour madame
le pen pourquoi parce que si vous avez
un second tour le pen faisait me le pen
ou zemmour versus macro c'est évidemment
toujours emmanuel macron qui gagnera
donc dans les élevages et gagne aussi
face à valérie payet pour le moment on
voit bien plus difficilement et vous
savez très bien que si les sondages
deuxième touche touche sont toujours
compliquées vous savez très bien que si
on veut avoir une chance rien n'est
jamais acquis en politique si on veut
avoir une chance de battre emmanuel
macron tu veux changer de président la
république en fait de dire va pas
refaire les cinq ans qu'on a fait parce
qu'il ya aucune raison que ça change
sera pareil avec des violences dans la
rue le désordre l'absence de ligne
politique
eh bien il faut toujours s'en voulait
changer vos débats grèce sur sur marine
le pen estime que la meilleure chance de
valérie pécresse et eric zemmour vous
partager ses analyses la meilleure
chance de valérie pécresse series
dérision c'est à dire que je sais pas ce
que ça veut dire je ne sais pas ce que
ça veut dire franchement je ne sais pas
ce que je vous disais la meilleure
chance de battre m annuellement
un mot rapidement finit bien puisque
vous êtes élue des hauts-de-seine comme
comme patrick balkany l'investisseur a
prononcé la révocation du placement sous
bracelet électronique des poubelles
kanje on sait que les républicains prône
la fermeté en matière de justice la
fermeté en matière d'application n'est
pas un scoop pour vous cette décision
est justifiée du peu mieux comment
voulez vous que je commente un dossier
que je ne connais pas que vous ne
connaissez pas que vous connais pas ces
problèmes compliqués c'est une décision
que je suis simplement
décision de justice s applique à aucun
commentaire à faire je veux pas d'un
côté dire moi je veux que la justice
soit soit soit fermée dirait critique in
justice justice injuste
ou une dernière question films suivants
et je m'adresse à l'ancien militaire
l'ancien médecin militaire qui était en
afghanistan quel regard sur la crise
malienne on a quelques secondes et c'est
plus qu'un exercice de style voilà en
quelques mots qu'est ce que c'est une
faillite diplomatique on a des soldats
qui sont là bas
ça coûte beaucoup d'argent à la france
ça coûte des vies de français on a des
soldats qui meurent pas tous les jours
heureusement mais souvent pour défendre
le valideur on est têtu de 5 entre
militaires a encore il ya quelques jours
et on a le mali qui nous traitent de
colonialiste
moi je voudrais savoir la france va se
faire marcher dessus pendant combien de
temps encore dans une partie non je suis
en train de vous dire qu'il faut que la
france est une politique
moi je ne sais pas où est la politique
française on a l'impression que dans
tous les coins du mond nous faisons
critiqué quels que soient les efforts
que nous faisons en fait nous avons
l'impression que la france est plus
gouverner et henri dié parce qu'elle ne
l'est plus merci philippe je vous
remercie beaucoup avoir été notre invité
ce matin là
[Musique]